the Joe Rogan experience with you as
soon as I got the pitch I was like I
need to talk to you like what you're
doing is insane and and amazing and very
very unusual that for someone have that
kind of patience and commitment to
something like that and to convert these
people and without judgment and to be
able to rationalize with them and talk
to them reasonably these are my fellow
American yes you know we all are we all
in this game together and sometimes
people get trapped in a really [ __ ]
stupid ideology yeah and they don't they
there's a part of their brain that knows
it's dumb there's a part of their brain
that knows it's toxic and they deny that
they ignore that they squash it and they
try to avoid thinking about it and then
someone like you comes into their life
and you kind of like open this door and
then Joe you know that a toxic thing
happens on both sides
you know I catch hell from people who
look like me not everybody you know but
they're they're people who look like me
who totally disapprove because you're
giving these people a platform because
I'm working with them yes yeah listen
you cannot change somebody's mind by
just allowing them to express what's on
their mind right you know well that's
the argument about deep platforming
people online right right but then the
argument the other way is that you're
radicalizing young people the argument
is there's a lot of young people that
would go on these social media sites and
and they're impressionable and they
don't know any better particularly
YouTube they worry about that because
these YouTube videos they have music and
it's a multimedia experiment helling and
with a really good narrator you can get
people to look at this [ __ ] flat
earth movement right where's that coming
from it comes from a few articulate
narrators who put together these videos
on YouTube where they're the only ones
you get to talk scientists don't get to
interject good stop that's wrong that's
not how I'll show you nope it's like
this look here's a satellite photo look
here's a hundred satellite photos look
here's all the satellites to take
pictures of the earth they don't get to
do that so these guys they they'll have
this long uninterrupted narrated video
that makes so much sense you you listen
to this guy guys he's changed oh my god
the world
I can't believe they're [ __ ] lyin to
me so there's hundreds of thousands of
people that believe in the Flat Earth
now because they've been radicalized
because they've been converted by these
multimedia things like YouTube this is
what people worried about in terms of
radicalizing them towards hateful
ideologies as well and I'm glad you're
using that word radicalized yeah cuz
that's exactly you're spot-on because
you know we was until recently that we
began using that word domestically we
know for a while they were only using it
for from middle-eastern type people you
know when when somebody like Dylan roof
did what he did we didn't say he was
radicalized so you know he must have
some mental issues but it's both isn't
it well sure I mean anybody walks in has
let him start shooting up people and has
mental issues yes but but they but they
have beacon what what allowed then
become radicalized maybe those mental
issues yes you know but but we don't we
don't say radicalize when it comes to
our own yeah because we're shamed of it
so many different code words for example
what do you call these groups of white
people who go out in the woods and
practice maneuvers and survival of stuff
survival of stuff they're like
anti-government kind of a paramilitary
yeah like what do they call them
malicious exactly right okay militias
all right what do you what do you call
the same type of things with black
people I didn't know they call them they
call them militants Oh like the Black
Panthers okay okay right right so what
you know it's that same thing right but
one term hasn't has more of a negative
connotation militias got a pretty
negative connotation not as negative as
militant yeah yeah yes no it seems to
say [ __ ] to me and let's take back when
when Obama got into office we had a new
political party that came out of nowhere
the Tea Party the Tea
right last time you heard of a tea party
was in 1776 what happened to them those
Tea Party folks they're still floating
around
really yes mm sells a tea party no
because Obama's gone now I think they
were out by the time he mean it was
before he was even gone didn't they fall
apart because he got a second term you
know they didn't work but but their
their slogan was take our country back
we take our country back okay take
America back
that is a Klan slogan hmm okay and it
was a code term for the Tea Party that
that was a clarion call and people it
resonated with a certain ilk of people
that slogan started in 1954 with the
Klan 1954 when Brown versus the Board of
Education desegregated schools you [ __ ]
you to find all these Klan rallies with
these wizards in translating with the
burning cross and balancing whether I
take our country back
I'm not gonna let my little white boys
and girls go to school little [ __ ]
children and blah blah blah
well not take our country back back the
segregation didn't want integrate it
right so I would ask these tea party
people why are you using a Klan slogan
and it's uh Nana now Darrell that's not
what we mean
I said well you don't say take our
country back from who you don't say take
our country back to what you say take
our country back or kind of open-ended I
said you know what would you know we
trying to say uh what we mean is we will
not take our country back from the
Democrats take it back to Republican
rule okay that's fine
why not say that
exactly they're using an already used
slogan the right take a case exactly so
it harkens to those people right and
here's the thing last time I checked
Bill Clinton was a Democrat Jimmy Carter
was a Democrat
where was the Tea Party where was taking
our country back and then all of a
sudden a black guy gets in the White
House and they start screaming take our
country back
right you can put two and two together
right where were you guys eight years
ago it's the four years ago yeah is that
right
[Applause]